this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck this podcast
has bad words
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
ryan in the modern world it seems we
have all the things we don't need
and we need the things we don't have
but we're so disconnected from our
communities that
bartering seems nearly impossible
yeah we don't even think about bartering
when we're talking about
acquiring goods and services wait this
is about bartering i thought it said
bartending
well we are going to talk about
bartering today and so we're here with
josh klein he's the founder of
have need it's an organization that
matches the haves
and the needs of people from around the
block or around the world
other josh thank you for being here
thank you brother josh it's a pleasure
to be here ryan
thank you both for having me yeah it's
great to have you what a what a cool
concept
talk about it
so the background of the concept wasn't
some inherent love of bartering it like
i didn't grow up in a in a
you know a commune where it was all
based on bars bartering was not your
passion
yeah it wasn't my passion the passion
was
um i came to a place a few years ago
where i wanted to be
in a position to do something more
impactful
frankly that was it i i was you know
25 plus years into my career it's been
fulfilling
but i didn't feel like i was actually um
as my dad said all the time growing up
like
leave the campground nicer than you
found it yeah and so that's always
in the back of my head and frankly like
my campground felt very small what was
your career
i've spent most of my career working in
media tech digital media
production technology review and
approval systems online systems
and you know i help people
make film and tv but
that's a small campground right and so
i just came to this place about you know
with my skill set
because you know i'm not an oncologist
i'm not a nuclear physicist
i'm not going to figure out waste water
solutions
what can i do to expand that campground
how can i help people at some scale
given my skill set and that sort of
boiled down to this idea of
well where are the broad swathes of
opportunity to help people so the next
you know couple billion internet users
will be coming online
via smartphones they'll have smartphones
they'll have internet access and they'll
have little or no money
okay how do you help those people
have a better quality of life but make a
business out of it not
not a charity instagram
wait a minute make them feel worse about
themselves versus everyone else
we can do this let's go guys lots of
money doing it well
let me let me say this real quick i got
this stat from you josh uh
last year the bbc reported that the
bartering economy is experiencing a
comeback
which i would have thought the opposite
during a pandemic it's like i don't want
to touch your stuff don't get around my
stuff
uh stay six feet apart whatever it is
and
of course that's probably part of it but
there's something else going on here
where we understand that it's not just
about exchanging currency
for goods and services yeah so once you
get away from
exchanging currency or even the ability
to exchange currency because over the
last year we've got you know
tens of millions of people 20 million
people lost their jobs in the united
states alone
so hundreds worldwide now you've got
broad swathes of the population that
have no money literally have no money no
jobs
but they have needs mm-hmm and people
have these things don't go away
right the needs never go away the money
goes away
the the things the stuff that people
have shoved in their storage units
those are still there yeah well it's
bigger than ever too yeah
and and people's ability to provide
services are still there like
maybe i've got an ability to go you know
generate some income here but
i need somebody to watch my kid yeah
things like that
so what's happened over the course of
this pandemic
is that communities are turning towards
barter
and and of course the pandemic raises
issues
about who you want to be around and who
you feel safe uh
interacting with but you know around the
world i mean i've just been
you know collecting articles from around
the world over the past year about
communities turning to bartering
and they find ways to do it uh as safely
as they can
and um there are some pretty funny like
uh
john legend and chrissy teigen had
something where they traded like
lettuce for bread with somebody in
studio city
and they used like one of their kids
little cars and they like
pushed it across the parking lot
so people will find a way if you if you
can generate
value for value people will find a way
to do it to make their lives better well
we're talking about needs so the things
we need we often mistake those for the
things we want
or what ryan and i we often say the
things we like which are things that we
don't even want but we think we want
yeah and
once we get them we realize that our
desires aren't actually what we desired
in the first place in fact the objects
of our desire become
the objects of our discontent in many
ways we have a rule we have a minimalist
rule book
you can download it at the
minimalists.com rulebook
it's 16 rules for living with less but
they're not real rules they're just sort
of like
loose recipes that you can apply to your
life but one thing stands out to me ryan
and i have this
rule called the no junk rule and and
really what we're identifying here is
everything that you own can be placed in
one of three piles it's either essential
those are the needs we're talking about
right or it's the non-essentials
those are the ones the things that will
probably add value to our life but
they're not
absolutely essential i can get by
without a
coffee table but it does add value to my
life and then there's the junk
and fortunately just because something
is junk for me doesn't mean
it's going to be junk for someone else
and that's really work
another person exactly and so that's
really where this this idea of bartering
uh comes into play now this is a a
listener driven show so
as we talk about bartering here i
thought maybe we would answer some
questions ryan we have a question from
facebook
what would the world look like if there
was no such thing as money
which has a vice lik vice like grip on
the material world
that is what would the world look like
if it ran strictly on
barter and that question is from cindy
on on facebook so
um you know these sort of absolutes are
fascinating sort of thought experiments
and once upon a time we didn't have
currency
right yeah and so there was a time in
egypt right let's pop
you know 8 000 years ago that's that's
where we believe
barter first arose for trade in egypt
interesting
and so you know economists argue whether
it's the the first form of currency or
not
um there there are two sides to that
argument but we know that there was
bartering
based on artwork from ancient egypt and
then
you know other cultures started
traveling through egypt
and then it became harder to barter
i didn't actually realize i was going to
rhyme until i said it was good
but it became more difficult to barter
so then we get the rise of currency you
know this equals that
right so why did it become difficult
well if you've got
somebody uh you know a group going
through
from the far east and they're trading
silk for instance
and they're traveling through egypt if
something they have
isn't something you need then you don't
you don't have this
sort of intermediate store of value
right where you can swap these things
out so
i need food i don't
and i and i have silk right but you
don't need silk right you need a goat
right so then all of a sudden we we run
into this thing that
that economist coined uh the mutual
coincidence of wants
and this is you know the holy grail
you've got to get
past uh for for successful scalable
bartering
so the mutual coincidence of wants is
for instance say it's youtube because
it's the
the t-shirts here you you want
ryan's short sleeve t-shirt but ryan you
don't want josh's
long-sleeve t-shirt right so i want a
goat right
so you don't share a mutual coincidence
of wants right
so but what if i'm here and i have a
goat
and josh wants this bracelet
now we've literally sidestepped this
thing between the two of you this mutual
coincidence of wants we've gone right
around it
and we've created a multilateral trade
where um we're able to do that now
with technology um it's very difficult
to do that
uh in an analog way totally makes sense
so the larger the population gets the
harder it is for this holy grail to
happen
exactly and so it just doesn't scale
it's never scaled
so um i hate to say to answer the
question is
what would the world look like well
previously there was just no way to even
contemplate that right because you can't
conduct these
transactions at any sort of scale
because you keep running into
you know bartering can be massive things
like the the tools of diplomacy the
levers of diplomacy are kind of barter
right hey we're going to send in a whole
bunch of human aid into your country but
in exchange we want you to be you know
democratically elected that's just
trading
and so it's just very complicated to
address those issues
um without sort of purpose-built
platforms and so on
the large scale you know very large
businesses are able to do it in very
complex ways
but on the human level we've never been
able to do it
right and so to answer cindy's question
directly is
we don't need it to be binary all
currency or all bartering
one can fill in the holes where the
other one doesn't work as well for you
for whatever reason yeah
exactly yeah i'm i'm not a bartering
zealot
right it's like barter or bust man
[Laughter]
it's that that's not where my head's at
at all if you got to pay the rent you
got to pay
the rent right right and so you know
there are just so many transactions
where you need
currency because maybe your landlord to
whom you're writing a rent check
he's got to pay the lease on that
building like they're just
institutions that will only accept cash
hard currency
right but even there i saw on your
facebook page you were talking about
uh for an exam example if you have an
electrician
who can provide a service to an
accountant the accountant can then do
their taxes and so
you can there are examples of businesses
that barter with each other
all the time this is super common in
like uh chiropractic world
and massage therapy world okay because i
have a really good chiropractor and i'm
like dude you do such an awesome job i'm
like who does this for you
and he's like oh i got a buddy we trade
back and forth adjustments and the same
thing
with massage therapy yeah yeah so one to
one trade there
right but you could also do it like with
the plumber hey if you come fix my
toilet i'll adjust your back right yeah
absolutely
and that works that's a that's a great
example of this like
contractors anytime you see a truck with
a magnetic sign on the side of it right
is that person operating at 100 labor
utilization probably not and there are
probably things that person needs
maybe that plumber needs a chiropractic
adjustment yeah
and would be very happy to fix
somebody's sink if he could get his back
cracked
right absolutely right and so what
you're not saying you're not out
proselytizing bartering in the sense
that this is what we
should do and it's not that it's more
virtuous than currency
it's simply that it gives us the ability
if we don't have
the cash or if we have a a skill or
service or
we simply have something we no longer
need that is junk in our life
which let's be honest here if the
average household has 300 000 items and
most of them are junk
we have a lot of things with which we
can barter yeah we have a lot of stuff
it's funny uh oftentimes in
conversations i'm the one
like like spouting out these details and
statistics about how much crap we've
stored but like
i'm in a tough room for that so well i
don't know all the stats either so
feel free to pepper them in but what is
really visceral for people
yeah that's what's visceral if you look
around so if you're listening to this
right now you're doing the dishes or
you're on the treadmill go into your
house and just simply
pause for a moment look around most of
the things you own more than likely if
you're
like the average american or average
person in the western world you know
only half our audience is american
but look around your house most of that
stuff is making you miserable yeah
right and it was so important the day
you bought it so
important right you might have saved up
or gone into debt for it yeah and you
felt it was gonna fill this hole in your
life
and it made it wider and the second you
got it you turn your attention to the
next thing
yes yeah yeah so the object a is what uh
the philosopher peter rollins talks
about where where it's the thing that
we're willing to sort of set fire to our
life for
in order to uh obtain so it could be a
relationship a marriage moving to a new
city a job
or a fancy car whatever it is it's like
i have to have it no
matter what and so when we're thinking
about
bartering or acquiring things the first
thing to think about is
do i actually need it or is it something
that someone else told me that i
wanted and if that's the case then i
don't even need the thing in the first
place and then
i don't need to barter for it but right
now when we're talking about bartering
why do you think it's becoming more and
more appealing
so it's tapping into a few trends
uh one is people are broke as a joke yes
right so that's that's one it's so
trendy to be broke right now
it's hit man everyone's doing it right
but uh so i was broke before it was cool
right exactly
i'm sorry so before before uh even
before the pandemic so a couple of
statistics here
uh about two out of three americans
almost two out of three americans
couldn't absorb a 500
emergency without going into debt so
we're the richest country on the planet
and two out of three of us couldn't fix
their transmission or their fridge
without borrowing the money putting it
on a credit card
so that is a large
group of people who would barter given
the opportunity
and then all of a sudden they lost their
jobs so they weren't just one paycheck
away from despair
they were in despair they were
financially displaced and so
necessity is the mother of invention now
people are looking around their
communities and takes
all these sorts of stories about one
person in a community setting up a
facebook group
or within the next door neighborhood for
their
neighborhood and setting up a little
group for bartering saying hey i know
we're all suffering right now
but we all have things and services and
maybe we can help get through this
and so some of these groups very quickly
uh you know
thousands of members jump in there
because there's this like
silent sea of suffering out there that
you know
not a lot of people brag about how
shitty their lives are right
hey i'm so broke i can't afford [ __ ]
so but one once they know once the
community makes it clear like hey we're
all
suffering then this this goes in this
next theme which is
bartering is very community oriented
yeah right it is
it is a community oriented experience it
connects you
to people in your community and at a
time over the past
year when sort of the underpinnings of
what we thought
our lives were were just ripped out from
under us
people turned to their friends and their
families and their communities
for strength and now within your
community it was
okay to raise your hand and say i'm
suffering
um i you know food banks are like
you know being picked dry and stuff so
people are okay to like line up i'm sure
we saw the news stories
there were food banks around the country
where you'd see nice
cars lined up yes yeah for hundreds of
yards or
like longer really nice cars people like
an alexis or something driving up to a
food bank because they'd lost their jobs
they were paycheck to paycheck
they were this goes to stories you guys
have told a lot like
i thought i needed a nice car i thought
i needed a nice house i thought i needed
that nice house
filled with tons of stuff and then they
lost the job
and they couldn't afford any of it and
now they're in a line to get
food at a food bank i made two hundred
thousand dollars a year almost in in
dayton ohio
which is you know in l.a what is that a
million yeah yeah well
except i was broke is the problem right
because i had two lexuses
lex i is the plural i believe yes and
and
and i realized like oh i'm i'm i am
still living paycheck to paycheck ryan
who was making great money as well we
worked the same corporation he was
living paycheck to paycheck yeah and the
thing you're talking about when you're
driving in the lexus through the food
bank
it illustrates the the
priority mismatch that we have in our
lives oh why do i buy a lexus was to sh
to telegraph who i am to other people
so next door has one i want him to think
that i'm doing as well as he is yeah or
joe next or doesn't have one
yeah and that's why i really want one
right because
toyota yes i have the legs yeah i want
the toyota that cost thirty thousand
dollars more
basically yeah uh so you got the badge
out i feel better about myself
that's exactly it now i think one one
thing you're touching on here is
bartering is becoming less taboo in a
way
because we're talking about a lot of
things right now we're talking about
suffering
in in our culture we're talking about
mental health a lot more now that was
something that was really taboo to talk
about
and so we had these certain taboos that
if you talk about mental health you must
be a weak person
or if you're bartering you must be broke
and therefore being
broke is a morally bad thing
right right you're a bad person you
don't have enough money you're a bad
person right
right where'd that where did that
connection come from
exactly well where i think it comes from
is
we are told by advertisements and
corporations
that we should aspire to be a certain
version of
ourselves right and that the
quote-unquote best version of me
looks like this and that person isn't
broke
right you're making money you've got two
lexi
you're vacationing in cabo right all the
good stuff you're a good person
yes morally good and where we confuse
like pleasure
with with goodness but there's something
else here that is becoming trendy that
you mentioned
it and it's that we are now
wanting to reuse things recycle things
be more environmentally
responsible absolutely that's why
minimalism is
is becoming uh more and more trendy
because i you know people are seeing
that it's not sustainable we have to
come up with a different solution
so you know things like free cycle which
has been around for however long
now it's picking up now it's starting to
pick up yeah and this is why um this is
why have need is starting to gain some
traction too is because i think there is
a little bit of
i'm an optimist i'm gonna just say
there's like a little bit of an
enlightenment happen happening i feel
like in society when it comes to
consumption
i'm with you on that yeah i i believe i
i think it's not hard to pick out
individuals that are just shits
but i think holistically people are good
yes
so i think the shits are an aberration
and i think people are trending as a
holistically in a positive direction and
to your point
that's the next big point next big trend
that influences why
uh bartering is picking up steam yeah so
it's not just you're broke
it's not just that you need connections
back into your community that you may
have lost with your screens and your
devices and your insular life
now we're all screwed so now we're
literally we're all in this together
right so
that's community and then the next thing
that layers in with that
absolutely is this sense that the way
we're doing it isn't working
we're dumping i'll probably get the stat
wrong but i think
last year in america it was like 146
million
tons of crap into landfills yeah
right and so that's not sustainable so
if i've got stuff and um
i'm not using it anymore i can
sell it i as you guys say i can sell it
i can donate it or i can throw it away
but there's this other pillar in there
if
if there's value stored in it that i
want to extract some value from
but it's not so much that i took the
time to put it on ebay
right right but it's still an old ipad
sitting on a shelf somewhere
it's just time is money i haven't kind
of gotten around it
but i would like something for it um and
it may just be donating it directly to
somebody i know can
can use it and will improve the quality
of their life that would make me that's
the currency sometimes i want
yes but also sometimes i would like
something for it
that may not be money so there's this
kind of this
silo in there where trading uh
is it's communal it's it's a
core tenant of a like a circular economy
right so i'm done with this thing but
it's not depleted of value
so i'm going to move it to you yeah
you've got something whether it's a good
or a service
and and josh you're going to move it to
ryan right so
i don't need it right now maybe you need
it tomorrow maybe you need it the day
after that
yeah if we live in a commune we just put
it in the middle here right
right and we go and get it and we trust
it it'll go back there and it won't be
broken the next time i need it
so we don't live in a commune right and
i think
a way we address that is through
bartering so i need it now
because people have tried like these
shared resource pools in small towns
people have tried um like rental like
community
sharing or rental startups yeah and and
i'm i'm not sure i've got it right
either yeah all i can do is point to
things that haven't worked and try to do
something differently
there's a free freeloader problem there
right yeah well they always talk about
the chainsaw like that's one of those
things
like most people unless you're a
lumberjack
you don't need a chainsaw every day but
you bought one and so there's value in
this thing and you're not ready to just
give it away because you know when you
need the chainsaw you need the chainsaw
right but some somebody borrows the
chainsaw out of the community
garage and then they break it they
didn't oil it the chain breaks and then
they just you know
late at night they're like here's a
[ __ ] chainsaw bag and then now nobody
else gets to use the chainsaw
right so if you've exchanged something
of value with your community
um now it's mine now now i it it belongs
to me now it's yours to break
yeah it is it's mine to break at least
for now and maybe when i'm done with it
i'll move it on to the next person who
needs it however long now is now can be
a
a moment it could be a day it could be a
year however long
that period on a long enough timeline
everything is ephemeral and
you don't own any of it anyway and even
if you can heap it into your casket it's
not going to do you
any good yeah i noticed one other thing
is it's also sort of becoming cool
there's this woman who is working with
us on our new studio space i can't wait
to move into the
new studio space by the way we're in a
temporary spot right now if you're
watching this on youtube
stay tuned real soon we'll be in a new
studio space and she's working with us
she just has this beautiful her name
is um beulah and like the city in
north dakota and um not missoula no
no rhyming shawn's happy place yes yes
indeed um
so uh she has this beautiful design
aesthetic she runs this
garment company clothing company called
uh gold morning
but it is repurposing clothes she's
probably the most stylish person
that i know if i look at her instagram
account it's all
or not all but the vast majority second
hand clothing
but it looks so much better than any
brand new thing off the shelf because
when you have that aesthetic sensibility
so there's also this
there's something cool about being able
to
be intentional with the things that you
bring into your life so
she does a type of bartering where she
sells old
clothing online and does so in a way
that's
very intentional and it's not mass
market and so
it doesn't have an ebay store with like
a thousand tchotchkes in it right
right it's it's like here's one blazer
it's a one of one or here's something i
designed it so she also does art so
she's she's a photographer and a painter
and and even that is just well curated
and
intentional and she's using some of
those things to fund
an adoption that she's going through
right now and so she's she's trying to
adopt
and and in doing that transferring value
exactly yeah and so by getting rid of
some of these garments she's no longer
using or wasn't going to use
now she is adding value to someone
else's life but it's also adding value
to hers
and i think ultimately that's what we're
talking about when we're talking about
bartering
i'm going to talk to her at some point
yeah yeah she's she's one she sounds
fascinating she really is ryan what time
is it you know what time it is it is
time for the lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts go
to both of our phones we even respond to
some of them
we respond to some folks on the podcast
as well so
josh during the lightning round so we do
our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response
but not really we just monitor on a bit
and podcast john
finds something beautiful something
pithy that's tweetable i've heard the
word pithy thrown around a lot yeah
yeah so some sort of maxim that we put
together in fact we call them minimal
maxims
you can find them in our show notes as
well or over at minimalmaxims.com
elizabeth has a question for us right
bartering has been around forever
but seems to have fallen out of favor in
recent times
why so i think we've covered this a
little bit but maybe
we can we can dig down a little bit
deeper here i have a
a minimal maxim for you society has
encouraged us to disconnect from
humanity
but humans would be better served if we
disconnected from societal norms
so i think that's tweetable really what
i'm saying here is
we've been encouraged to live a
particular way you're supposed to live
this way as we talked about
a moment ago and that way that we live
that societal way being of
society being of the world as they say
has actually disconnected us from our
humanity
in many ways and i think in a way
bartering is getting us
back closer to this thing called
humanity
yeah i'll let you expand on that josh
i think um that's profound
no joke it's a profound concept
and i think it goes back to uh
humanity is sort of an extrapolation of
community
right like i i could boil down to you
know in my mind the meaning of life
is um to the extent that the human brain
can
even you know put logic to it is is to
connect
right as far as i know i'm here for a
few laps around the sun
and what what brings meaning to my life
is the connections i have with other
people
yeah so you know currency isn't even
part of that conversation right humanity
around making connections with people is
and it just doesn't have to be out
bartering could be like helping people
yes right lending a hand being part of
somebody's life uh
adding something to somebody's life is
is bettering humanity on some level that
goes back to leave the campground nicer
than you found it
so if bartering is certainly not the
end-all be-all
for that concept but it's a part of that
concept
it's hey we're literally all in this
together
and there's a way we can uh without it
being a donation every time
from one to the other hey we can we can
like
lift each other up through this we can
all help each other i need stuff
you need stuff and that stuff can be i
need
i would like to learn how to speak
spanish right so
i've got a dresser laying around that i
don't use
and i'm listening these guys the
minimalist they've convinced me my
dresser sucks i've got to get it out of
my life it's ruining my life
so i don't need the dresser anymore but
you speak really good spanish and
english and so
we can help each other out and now our
little corner of humanity
was just elevated a tiny little bit
we're both a little better off
today than we were yesterday right yeah
i like that bartering is
is another way to help people that we
never even consider yeah what you were
talking about josh makes me think
um and this might be pithy enough to
tweet but uh
the more uh the the more we consume
uh the less we commune like the men
the less community like the uh but
they're great there's something there
with like the
more the the the more we yeah the more
consumption
the less community some something around
there i like your time was better
yeah yeah okay okay thanks that was
great all right sean edit all that out
and
i'm kidding i'm kidding um the the one i
have written down here is the right
thing to do is really
is rarely the easy thing to do and
here's the thing is
money is the it's the shortcut and that
is what
uh we use money for and whether it's to
buy happiness or
or whatever it is money is kind of this
shortcut it's what
it's what takes us away from that holy
grail that you were talking about and it
and it creates this shortcut to getting
things that we need
so unfortunately i think the reason why
we're moving away
from this bartering uh system is because
it's it's a lot more intentional it's a
lot harder to do in some ways
so that's what's so great about what
you're doing is you're saying hey um
i will put up a system that makes it a
lot easier
to barter and you're kind of removing
that that barrier of entry which is
which is
fantastic what do you mean by the right
thing
uh how did i just use it
and your pithy answer oh the right thing
to do is really the easy thing to do
the the thing that well it depends
in reference to this question the right
thing would be
to trade goods
rather than create new goods and consume
new goods
so uh yeah
yeah yeah i know that um there is this
this whole value judgment that can be
said with that but in relation to her
question yeah
it's it's the the easy thing to do is to
just
put out a couple bucks and get that
tchotchke and throw the
other thing away right but when you do
that you are hurting the environment
you're using resources and then now
we're doing this on a massive scale
so um the right thing in in that
situation
is to um consume less and contribute
more basically so what would the wrong
thing be then
that's exactly what i just told you what
the wrong thing was it's to consume
the wrong no the wrong thing to do is to
uh endlessly use resources
okay yeah yeah i agree but we all use
resources so i don't think that it's
strong
to use resources i'm just trying to
understand the yeah no that's
yeah that's not what that's not what i
said josh has been on this um
zen kick lately where no value he's he's
really trying to take away value
judgments from things so he's
i'm just trying to understand what you
think is right here right exactly yeah
are you sure you meant that right
exactly right exactly exactly
i have to be very careful at the time i
always had to like work through an
answer yeah i have to be very careful
with the words i use around melbourne no
the wrong thing to do to be to create
and consume
needlessly when there's a better option
okay
um do you need me to expound more no i
think i i okay i understand awesome
awesome all right cool we got a bunch
more to talk about but first ryan what
you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out
hi fellow minimalists i just wanted to
leave this
tip because it has been a recent
shift in my way of thinking on the
podcast when i used to hear people or
even josh and ryan discussing like
consuming consciously and thinking about
the companies where they purchase things
i felt like that was too much work to do
the research behind
companies and recently i've kind of
realized that
my power in a way comes from
the things that i'm spending my money on
in our current society and so
it actually seems like a very small
price to pay
to do the research and purchase
products from places that care about the
environment
and that treat their employees
well because i suppose the alternative
is spending money on
goods and places that maybe don't care
about their employees
and don't treat the environment well and
then if i
am purchasing from them then in a way i
am supporting
those behaviors which don't align
with my values hi josh and ryan
this is gina calling from hershey
pennsylvania i have a listener tip for
finding free reading material for avid
readers on a budget
there's the local library which we're
usually the most familiar with but there
might be other larger libraries
available to you within your state
for example as a pennsylvania resident
you can access the materials at the
philadelphia free library
absolutely for free which is a much
larger collection than my local library
i use an app called overdrive and log in
with my local and state library
information
i have two different collections to
search from without ever stepping foot
into this library i've downloaded
countless audio and ebooks
it works just like a regular library if
something isn't available you can place
a hold and you'll be notified when it's
ready
i'd recommend doing some research for
your state to see if there are other
libraries you might not have known that
you have access to
all right y'all thanks again to josh
klein for joining us today
check out have need he describes it as a
dating app
for your stuff it's in beta mode right
now you can
download the app for free if you put in
the code minimalists it will
track so he'll know how many people came
from this podcast we don't get anything
for that
but it is a bartering app that allows
you to not just get rid of the things
that you don't need anymore but also
obtain some of the things
that you might need so you have some
things that you can list on the app
but you might need some things that you
can list that on the app
as well it's called have need we'll put
a link to that in the show notes
also on the patreon episode on this
thursday we're going to talk about the
difference between
have need and free cycle and craigslist
and buy nothing all of which can be
beneficial
so it's not like it's a competition but
we're going to talk about the
differences between
those different platforms real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist actually two things because
it's my birthday next week next tuesday
is my
40th birthday would you like to get me a
birthday gift
well you can you can get me two gifts
actually i don't usually ask for this
once or twice
a year we don't do this every episode
please rate and review our podcast but
if you want to get me a
birthday gift you can you can rate and
review our podcast
on apple podcast if you get value from
this podcast
it's one of the best ways to help our
message reach more ears
head on over to apple podcast even if
you don't listen on apple podcast
leave us a rating and a review and that
will be the best
birthday gift you can get me or you can
also pre-order our new book it's called
love people use things i'll hold it up
if you're watching this
video on youtube it comes out in three
weeks love people use things because the
opposite
never works you can pre-order it right
now wherever you pre-order books your
local bookstore
amazon barnes and noble or just head on
over to lovepeopleusethings.net
you can find the details you can also
see the beautiful trailer that jordan
shot
for the book love people use things.net
it's a relationship book it's about the
seven
essential relationships in our life and
it comes out in three weeks on july 13th
2021. for our added value this week i
headed over to apple music and i typed
in the word
need and i found a bunch of different
songs that have the word
need in them and i picked my favorite
it's a guy named j william henderson one
of my favorite albums of all time is
called
the sun will burn your eyes he's from
utah
which by the way some of the best music
in the world comes out of utah in fact
both soundtracks to both of our films
were produced by a producer
out there in utah nate pifer and
the band that he created which is called
we but this
is a song from j william henderson one
of my favorite musicians this is called
maybe you got all you need he has this
line in there about
maybe you've got all you need to fight
this war
and just made me think that a lot of us
are suffering
and we continue to suffer more because
we think we need
more but maybe we have all we need
already
to end our suffering this is j william
henderson
maybe you got all you need we have a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like
how is have need different from the buy
nothing project or free cycle
what are some of the best examples of
modern day bartering
is there a way to screen the person you
want to barter with
plus a million more questions about the
things we need about bartering and so
much more and if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week
visit the minimalists.com support to
subscribe and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
you help keep this podcast 100
advertisement free but
when you become a supporter of the
podcast you also get access to
all of our archives so not just that
extra episode every week that longer
maximal episode every week but you get
all of our archives which there are
hundreds of hours of minimalism
in the archives some of the best
conversations we've ever had you can
find there
the minimalists.com support you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram
at the minimalists come to one of our
live podcast shows visit
the minimalists.com tour to find a city
near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip email
at voicememo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist if you want our
show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any news minimalist writings that we
publish
simple sunday email we send that out
whenever we have something new to
communicate any new minimalist writings
and if you leave here today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it